Thankfully, one of the biggest scams in the
American tax code
is finally under attack in the House version
of Republican tax reform.
It's the mortgage-interest deduction,
which currently lets homeowners deduct interest
paid on mortgages
of up to $1 million for two houses.
Ever since owning a home has been a central
tenet of the American Dream
since the end of World War II and the rise
of suburbia,
it's been a given that deducting mortgage
interest from your taxes
is as American as apple pie.
The House plan would limit filers to deducting
interest on the first $500,000
of a mortgage on just one house,
sending a blind panic through wealthy home
owners, realtors, and the building trades,
all of whom are terrified that a government
subsidy is being yanked away from them.
We are very concerned with the limitation
on the mortgage interest deduction
and it's really limited in two ways-
But the real problem with the House bill is
that it doesn't go far enough.
We should scrap the mortgage-interest deduction
altogether
and let housing prices reflect real market
values.
The mortgage-interest deduction is typically
justified by claiming that it lets people,
especially vaguely defined "middle-class"
people, afford homes.
But it also increases the price of housing
by making it artificially cheap to borrow money,
meaning homebuyers are willing to borrow more.
England, Canada, and Australia don't let their
taxpayers deduct their mortgage interest
and they all have higher rates of homeownership
than the United States.
The mortgage-interest deduction disproportionately
benefits the wealthiest Americans,
who soak up almost all the $70 billion a year
it costs in foregone revenue each year.
The tax bill, both the House and the Senate
versions,
both of them leave alone, for the most part,
the mortgage interest deduction,
which is one of the most ridiculous parts
of the tax code.
Reason Foundation's director of economic research,
Anthony Randazzo
calculates that only 20 percent of tax filers
claim the mortgage-interest deduction.
That group by and large are part of six-figure
households
in a country where the median household income
is just $57,000.
Killing the mortgage-interest deduction
might cause a one-time 7 percent drop in real estate prices,
according to one estimate, with wealthy homeowners
feeling most of the pain.
Speaking as a homeowner,
that seems like a small price to pay to end
a policy that distorts the real estate market,
complicates the tax code, and benefits mostly
wealthier Americans
all on the false promise that it makes home-owning
affordable for the middle class.
The mortgage-interest deduction is just special-interest
pandering
wrapped in a gooey story that equates "the
American Dream" with having a mortgage.
The tax code should be designed to raise the
revenue necessary
to pay for essential services,
not to nudge and prod us into spending money
on something the government decides is good
for us.
The House tax reform plan would be at least
a good down payment
on a more libertarian tax code.